more Little League teams and
underprivileged neighborhoods get the
kids interested and the parents will
follow make it more friendly as far as a
mission into the games because it it's
on a fortune to get into a game I'm a
science teacher so maybe setting up stem
programs and letting them know the
engineering associated with the stadium
and give the students involved and
different aspects are playing the game
not displaying the game even with
management and people skills probably if
I'd some type of hip-hop rapper
with swinging stadium or probably in
losing baseball commercial something
like that tree everybody the same and
then maybe a more people will come up
with what you have fear of coming out
Oh